greetings from podcast Ville the church
what's happening now is brought to you
by my bookie
listen ever since we started the pop
podcast people always asking me for
different type of advice if I know who's
gonna win who's got the over the under
listen the truth is I don't know who's
gonna win but if you think you know you
gotta check out my bookie why because
it's the only service I recommend to the
church or what's happening now listeners
and they've been good to me that's why
I'm urging you to make your way to my
bookie right now this weekend is the
second weekend of pro football and you
want to be on tap you understand me they
have in game live betting the most
rewarding player perks in the business
and for you fantasy guys out there you
can even bet the over and under you
follow us and here so do me a favor join
right now at my bookie will match your
deposit dollar for dollar use promo code
Church CH you are CH to activate the
offer visit my bookie online today
that's my bookie and don't forget to use
promo code Church on creating your
account you play you win you get paid
the show is also brought to you by
23andme
you guys are sitting there what's
23andme it's a DNA testing service that
could offer insights into your ancestry
health wellness and traits the 23andme
health and ancestry service includes
reports on how your DNA can influence
your weight sleep quality caffeine
intake sense of taste
whether you're likely to be lactose
intolerant and a lot of more what I'm
gonna do is this for the church family
order your 23andme health an ancestry
service kit at 23andme calm a slash
Church that's 23andme
dot-com slash Church CH you are CH
that's 23andme dot-com slash Church give
it a shot today kick that [ __ ]
meal way it's as good as it gets
uncle P what do you think love it love
it grew up on it yep really sons sons
playing it now he's an old soul really
yeah sons of the band no he's uh
studying music at the University of
Michigan just dropped him off for a
sophomore year and he's uh you know a
John Mayer wannabe at Jimmy Page wannabe
really yeah good for him yeah so he's
bringing this
he knows the lyrics to these songs
better than I do songs that I grew up on
what does he think about today's music
Wow so what is he nineteen twenty just
turn 19 he says rock is dying okay you
know it's those Foo Fighters keeping
them alive no Greta Van first of all
that's shocked me I'm like what do you
mean rocket scientist no you gotta
listen this everything is like you know
um sampled and you know computerized and
you you know um it's just different you
know so I said you know you should play
rock and you knows yeah but it's kind of
dated it's not at its height right now
which is shocking for me to hear because
that's what I grew up on but he's 19 he
knows I don't I mean it's it's I love it
I love it but it's getting old right now
like that all we have on the radio I
mean he'll listen to lithium I got
serious I listen to lithium I listen to
Ozzy's boneyard
there's got to be something else I
listen to what 60% of music on that has
Guns and Roses yeah that's all they play
they play a lot of Guns and Roses those
three or four arms and heavy rotation
and you know I love the Foo Fighters I
love David grow whatever they come out
with something you know I love that
these older bands are touring mm-hmm
because kids like yourself I'm going to
watch these guys
yeah whether it's Roger Waters or you
know I think next week is Judas Priest
and deep purple at the LA County Fair
Wow you know many people have invited me
to that next week and it sounds great I
mean I have isn't uh Eddie trunk and he
was talking about Oh or jim Florentine
he was talking about uh
that they're gonna do delivering the
goods they haven't done it in 40 years
what war wait a second they haven't play
the song and 40 [ __ ] years they'll
pull it out this year just the thought
that this storm Def Leppard and sold out
the garden Wow how did that happen
I don't know but so music is alive in a
way oh yeah just yes it's just evolving
as it always does it's just
interesting where it's going what's up
with you brother
Anna's working working we finished a
movie with just finished a movie in
starting a movie so I'm in like the the
vortex of hell right now so you're a
month away from starting anew yeah five
weeks away
you're making me poop a little because I
should be home writing right now cuz we
still got to finish the script okay you
know you could do that with your eyes
closed and yeah finishing one that opens
Thanksgiving Wednesday so that's all
with Jennifer that's one with Jennifer
Lopez so was that a romantic comedy it's
a comedy well people are calling it a
romantic comedy there's some romance in
it because there's Milo Ventimiglia who
uh all the chicks adore I mean it's
crazy you know how how popular it is
because of this is us
but it's interesting it's really not
their story I can't really say whose
story it is because it kind of gives
away a surprise but if people want to
think of it as a romantic comedy thing
about as a romantic comedy it's kind of
like if it were to be like something
working girl you remember that movie
right yeah you wanted it to go guy
directors now in Hollywood a family do
you have a lot of scripts coming your
way for comedic features I do it's you
know it's weird because not as many
comedies are being made today as there
used to be it's the big IP things ifs
it's a you know a comic book or a Disney
animated movie that they're turning into
live-action or book those are the movies
that studios want to roll the dice on
and the mid-range comedies whether
they're romantic comedies or r-rated
comedies you know hardly anybody's doing
them if it's if it's not new line or now
STX which is a studio that I've been
working at the past couple of years
they're the only ones doing it and it's
great that they are but it's not like it
used to be where you know you'd get
offers from paramount
and Warner Brothers and Fox I mean they
still occasionally make them but far
fewer of the mid-range movies that's
just nuts yeah I see you know Kevin
Hart's got a movie every six weeks yep
I know Kevin Hart's always doing some
our old friend even though they wrote
pulls the comedy out and find the time
right
you know but it's not like I know it's
when I was growing up there were two or
three smash comedies every year yeah
that [ __ ] your world up it was six or
seven good ones but three that [ __ ]
you up and Murphy you know somebody from
say arrives something right I don't see
that you know no no that's what I'm
saying it's uh you know it's kind of
like what we're talking about with music
it's evolving I don't know what's gonna
happen in the future I mean right now I
feel like there's so many superhero
movies that how can that sustain our
business and are we gonna look back on
it ten years from now and say remember
when we were in that period where all it
was was superhero movies or Disney which
seems to like own the planet earth right
now between Pixar and Marvel and Star
Wars it's just it's an interesting time
I loved Coco oh fantastic like I thought
it was I took my daughter I told it was
[ __ ] great
yeah those Pixar movies they take two or
three years to make but they [ __ ]
they're all home runs now absolutely you
know it takes a lot it breaks my heart
that I'm not the movie guy used to be
well you know what do you mean by that
you don't go as much Friday 11:30 I'm
that guy what time do you movie come out
Friday 11:30 where's that coming
comes out the Laemmle 11:45 and it comes
out in North Hollywood 6 and 11:15 I was
at the 11:15 in North Hollywood and I'd
schedule of a joint the Chinese food
before they'd have to be yogurt like I
had a process it just wasn't the movie
it was the whole thing right I don't
know if it's cuz I got married I don't
know I just went to the movies on a date
we got a date night we going to see
Mission Impossible the last 15 minutes
was an hour
blow the [ __ ] plane up already 15
minutes I'm waiting my ass is that I
wanna have a 15 minutes yeah the world's
got 15 minutes I'm sitting here now when
I have why is that [ __ ] out of it you
know why is this athlete I don't need
this [ __ ] my worlds and I went to see
the part to the equalizer yeah and again
nothing top man on fire after man on
fire could he shot himself in the head
cuz it was so good he was so good
benzoin man oh yeah yeah he was a great
drunk pilot yeah and he was okay as the
[ __ ] in whatever but you know it was
okay like I didn't remember anything
from I didn't come home and give you a
line yeah I didn't do any of that stuff
I was telling John now when I went to
see the wrestler I remember sitting
there during the wrestler I'm watching
Mickey Rourke somebody I loved early on
from the Pope of Greenwich Village and
then Angel Hardy's brilliant and I'm
like why did I come see this movie at 12
this was the first movie had gone back
to my old self like I went to see that
what's the expensive one on Sunset
Cinerama Dome yeah I don't give a [ __ ]
now get the six dollar [ __ ] chicken
sausage with the mustard and the onion
do you eat like a doctor I want you know
you going there you drop 50 there's no
man they prices there is nothing you
pick me what I'm talking about right
there
n'gou or is a gallery it's gonna rapido
yeah
you go under that's a yardstick and one
day you drop it easy easy popcorn you
always gotta get this chicken sausage
that's the sink this chicken sausage
with the [ __ ] mustard and onions
it's brilliant in there what we talking
about huh well I wanted a man watching
the wrestler and I'm thinking to myself
what made me come here because like
would Goodfellas I was in a halfway
house Pete I was in a federal halfway
out peanut I made up a whole story yeah
now I had to go to a hospital son no I
didn't had a joint I went for Chinese
food and I went to the first for you and
a ghost of Goodfellas or maybe seven
other people movie theatre I love that
[ __ ] oh yeah to be able to leave the
movie at 2:00 and tell people when I
move in they're like we're going tonight
don't bother you know a being a critic
that your friends like it's
dick you know I'm saying like I love
though that's the I don't do it no more
because there's nothing really that
grabs me the wrestler was the last one
that I went and I thought about what
made me go see it and it was something
right read online that's it mm-hmm you
know it's little things they don't
prepare you the movie studios don't
prepare you anymore it's such a running
gun business you got two weeks
advertising and I got a catch in three
days if not the movie moves up and
[ __ ] super fly and got here already
on paper me yeah well they know no one
watches commercials anymore who watches
currently everyone skips through them so
unless you're at the movies watching a
preview how are you finding out about
this movie now you have this here on
like Instagram or something like oh
that's true this movie that this movie
that we're advertising right now the
Jennifer Lopez one it's called second
act the way the movie is being
advertised is completely different it's
relying so much more on digital so you
know jennifer has like a hundred and
twenty million followers and she
released the trailer and I saw Dwayne
Johnson did the same thing for or
skyscraper that's a bigger reach than
they're gonna get you know on on a TV
show and it used to be a big thing in it
I guess it still is sort of but you know
Super Bowl spots but they're so
expensive now and people are going to
the bathroom during them so everything's
changing used to be television was the
biggest form of advertising now it's
digital and social it was so great oh I
was gonna say it's funny what you said
about your son cuz my cousin went to
Ithaca well in and he graduated and like
a year later they switched from film to
digital and he doesn't he he didn't last
cuz everything you went to school for
was out so it's we've been talking about
the change and it's just it's weird how
you excited sometimes you have no
control over it like you had like you
probably as a director I've had to adapt
about tons since you've shot that movie
with Joey or even three years ago the
whole business has probably changed a
few times it has changed I actually was
the guy blamed for
getting rid of film editing because my
first movie we edited on Abbott and it
was the first major motion picture to
have it to edit entirely digitally and
then I had people like who were mad at
me and like Bryan Singer on the end of
usual suspects puts you know this film
was edited entirely on film I thought
okay well that's fine it's just that I
liked I came from television where we
were editing digitally and I thought
well why aren't they doing this in film
and it was different back then you had
to hose down the mags literally they get
so hot and now it's you you don't have
half the machinery in the room so that
was that was how we edited and then from
a picture standpoint Dean Semler who
I've done four movies with who did the
longest yard and graduates and grudge
match he convinced me on Get Smart to go
digital not shoot film and he literally
took me to a theater in Hollywood and he
a bead the same scene from I forget what
movie and he said I want you to tell me
you guess what's film and what's digital
and I got it wrong every time I said
that's the film he goes no that's
digital and that one vice-versa so I
couldn't tell the difference I said okay
we should we should shoot digital and
now there's still a lot of directors who
want to shoot film Chris Nolan Tarantino
that's great but what they told me I
said why do you guys like as
cinematographer shooting digitally said
well you know paid you know I can never
go to sleep at night you know and I I
didn't know it if the film was develop
really I'm not
I'd have to wake up in the morning and
call the lab and now I know it instantly
it's done I'm like oh that's interesting
and I remember asking cuz Steve Carell
really liked shooting digitally and I
said why what are you sense as an actor
what difference does it make to you
because I remember hearing the film
running through the mag and I felt
pressure like we're spending money if I
don't get my scene funny or right but
digital I don't hear it and I hear it's
cheap tapes cheap that's so it calms me
down I'm like wow I never thought that's
crazy so two different perspectives so
I'm sorry I helped [ __ ] up the business
but
it is the way of future is the future
what do you have do you know everything
is evolving I mean everything has
evolved so much yeah and the way you
color time a picture which a lot of
people don't even know what that means
but if you look at old movie posters you
know Lawrence of Arabia on the poster
it'll say colorist and he got a credit
on a poster now no one even knows what
that is but it's literally changing the
colors of the picture now on film you
would add a point of yellow to the
entire screen or a point of green or a
point of blue and this would change you
know the color of your face if you
looked green and we wanted to make you
look tan you know you change for now
digitally you can colorize certain
sections of the screen it's much more
accurate and it's so fantastic if you
watch some of those films dartie The
Wizard of Oz and everything with Yul
Brynner King and I King in an original
West world the original West world you
could see that they [ __ ] around mm-hmm
you couldn't catch what it was you were
too young you didn't understand well but
you knew something wasn't right
especially with your brother your
brother always [ __ ] with me and I
don't know why his face always look too
tan it wasn't tan enough there was
something about your brother that always
[ __ ] with me how would the Longest
Yard be different if you were to shot it
digitally that would it you know you
know what it's it's an aesthetic choice
it's um it's cheaper right the home was
expensive I used to get when you would
shoot a million feet of film Kodak would
come out and give you a bottle of
champagne and that was considered a lot
and on the Longest Yard I got two
bottles of champagne and the studio was
pissed because they said you're shooting
too much [ __ ] film slow down like I'm
shooting football you know I have five
cameras going you know you watch an NFL
game on the weekend there's like 47
cameras that cover a football game I
couldn't do that but that's what I'm
competing against you know so we take
five cameras we move them around a
couple times and then it looks like I
have 25
cameras I'm still half of what the NFL
is shooting but shooting on film with
that number of cameras that was very
expensive and they're not making movies
you know the Sandler days that being one
of them where movies cost 80 million
know everything now is 20 or under now
no one's gonna feel sorry for us but
that was the business Nutty Professor
cost eighty five million
they wouldn't spend that today 85
million made a hundred and sixty but did
you know they don't green that's what
I'm saying they don't greenlight movies
in that world anymore the crazy thing is
Netflix still is paying big dollars you
know for the budgets of the Sandler
movies they're still big over there I
don't quite understand the business
model you know how they make money I'm
sure they do but it's just it's a new
era
you know there's streaming movies now
Netflix is gonna make big Oscar
campaigns for their movies they got a
Coen brother movie there's a an alfonso
quran movie last thing he did was
gravity remember and he's got a big one
coming out and so i I guess they put him
out in the theater for a weekend so it
qualifies for the Oscars but then you
watch him on Netflix you know if you got
a nice theater at home you know screen
and the surround sounds like why not it
was funny when you guys were talking
about movie theaters because my favorite
thing about living in LA and attacks
have been closed for about a year is
going to places like the new Beverly and
seeing old double features for six
dollars like that's what I think is is
kind of growing and the movie industry
is like people going back I go just want
AMC is really be releasing a smoky and
abandoned because of Burt Reynolds gonna
release it I'm sure every screening will
be sold out so it yeah
that's pretty fun the New Beverly that's
the Tarantino theater right right yeah
they really adore that played it was
awesome he played Tommy Boy two years
ago and it was it's 20 20th anniversary
and so I went and they had me do a
little speech in front
act house because I hadn't seen the
movie projected since the movie came out
once you know you go to the premiere
that's like the last time you see a
movie on a big screen most of the time
and I said wait wait wait wait how did
Quentin Tarantino have a 35-millimeter
print of Tommy Boy is it oh no he owns
one I said I don't even own a
35-millimeter print of my own movies but
he does and he has a vault and because
it got to be color you know sorry a
temperature-controlled so that the film
doesn't melt or decay and it and then I
had another screening of Tommy Boy at
the USC in the Frank Sinatra theater and
that print came directly from Paramount
and it was a piece of [ __ ] had scratches
all over it and everything Tarantino's
copy of the movie was better than
Paramount's it was fantastic so I loved
that day I love what he's doing was that
your first big Tommy you know first
movie I made when I was thirty was Naked
Gun finally you went to USC went to us
how long you stay in New York City for
New York to a zero through eight really
where'd you live
I lived Upper West Side 441 West End
Avenue then moved when I was five to
Mamaroneck what you go for public school
what public school would you go to oh I
don't know the name of them but Fe
bellows and Elementary if you want to
know no I live in an Upper West Side
really from those preschool I lived on
the Upper West Side from 66 to 73 oh
yeah I lived on you know 88th Street to
old far oh my god it we were like
neighbors yeah but I went to PS 166
that's why oh I you know my my sister
went to PS 109 I remember I don't
remember the number of my but still her
was a neighbor of ours too been still
right he's one of those guys a [ __ ] I
lived it block from Zabar's okay one
block okay and I grew up at the Natural
History Museum my grandparents would
babysit me and just to shut me up those
just take him to the museum he'll stop
crying how many times did you stay in
the middle and look at that whale up on
top I literally was just shooting this
and I spent seven months of this past
year in New York and I have so much deja
vu
I've been here when I was a kid yes I
remember my dad I went to Riverside Park
and I cracked my skull open I was riding
my bike down a path and I slammed the
brakes on went right over the handlebars
but right by the memorials it was going
down a hill into the park and I remember
my dad was like taken to the hospital
and and he bumps into Walter Matthau
who's walking Charlie Matthau in a
stroller and there's mold seal oh whoa
yeah and he goes I can't talk right now
Suns bleeding got taking the hospital
but they had worked together and I you
know I remember my dad telling me that
story I'm like that's nice so I kind of
met Walter Matthau you know I don't
really remember it my brains were losing
out of my forehead right by the Lincoln
Memorial isn't there a Lincoln Memorial
I don't beside drive yeah I like 90th
between like 85th and nineteen I could
be wrong there's a memorial that there
might be and my dad died when I was
young but I was baptized Catholic and my
godfather stuck to his word about sad
days he would pick me up and we'd take
me to like [ __ ] at first he got bored
a kid movies he'd take me to I thought
my bug oh yeah and he took me to the
world's greatest athlete loving Michael
Vincent with love in the arms and John
Amos kanjani most but one time he's like
how to do this took me to see the
valachi papers'
oh yeah and I was hooked no no the first
movie took me to see was Her Majesty's
Secret Service it's George Lazenby that
was the first Bond no he came in between
did he yeah he was the first 69 no they
had already made the ones with Connery
with Mallory
Oh is he after I thought he was but more
let's check it out he came in in 69 68
did one movie Her Majesty's Secret
Service with Kojak Diana Rigg well I was
in love we [ __ ] they had a raid as a
young kid so it was yeah there was three
it was he was in between Connery and
maybe the st. remember the TV show of
st. yeah that guy okay yeah absolutely
he only did one movie yeah and Kojak was
in it whatever the [ __ ] his name is
Telly Savalas Oh
Savalas so he would be played the bad
guy in the movie he was a third it looks
like there's a David Niven was did it
once what I do not remember that yes and
George Lazenby din 69 out of 69 George
Lazenby I would say David Niven was bond
what was the name of that movie when he
played Bond who David Niven Casino
Royale what that is so weird and 67
that's so weird so yeah after Sean
Connery they didn't know for sure when
did the guy from the st. come on the
same they'll tell you who was after
George Lazenby okay Roger Moore Roger
Moore he was the one oh oh he was the
shoulder saying he was the one though
that I remembered as a kid has a cane
raker I thought was my favorite that's
that was my favorite too yeah and by the
way so jaws the Richard Kiel who played
Jaws in in Moonraker but they brought it
over they brought him back for another
one he was also in the original longest
Lars yes see that's why I brought back
Dileep Singh who was in The Longest Yard
as my huge guy can get smart I was
completely that was an homage to Richard
Kiel in the original and Moonraker you
do a lot of lodges from time to time
Oh marshes are better than P lodges you
know you don't want to be stealing stuff
so you'd like to honor it you know so
yeah it doesn't feel like kind of like a
I'm not an easter egg but almost like a
little secret that you have that maybe
someone will find out but it's just it's
just really for you yeah so how long was
Peter Moore Roger Moore Roger Moore from
73 to 85 he did yeah seven of them and
then there was the good-looking Timothy
Dalton yeah that's right he did one to
two and then Pierce Brosnan 10 years
yeah I like Peace Prize I did - that's
where I grew up when the Daniel Craig's
been doing it since oh five but Daniel
Craig is such a great badass bond it's a
different bond in a change I love it I
like them I love him he did you know the
redo of Casino Royale you know written
by Paul Haggis and by the way the recent
one Specter the guy I'm now working with
dave bautista
was the bad dude in that and oh some
great scenes the the fight on the train
you know when you'd never think Daniel
Craig could beat the crap out of that
guy cuz that guy is a big nice a big
dude that's a big man what now are they
gonna replace Daniel Craig er though he
is like I think after the last one he
said I'm done I'd rather have C he said
something like I'd rather have sewing
needles poked in my eyes rather than do
another one of those and I think he was
just exhausted and then he came back and
said let me finish what I meant was and
he stayed well I mean yeah that's a
little bit I was just gonna bring up
they were the last I heard is that they
were considerate you know the one of the
rumors was II drew salba oh yeah I was
gonna be crazy and I was gonna get your
opinion on it because for me I mean I
didn't grow up with it but to have a
black James Bond doesn't really I don't
have a feeling either way do you guys
always say I'm lucky you're not gonna be
like oh I would never let a black eye do
it but I do guys get married to the way
things were and when they do remakes you
guys get upset if they change things or
well first of all I think you'd be
awesome secondly why not but third it
was interesting I experienced a little
bit of backlash on you know well Get
Smart wasn't a remake it was an
adaptation but Carell and I when we did
that we wanted to make it a little more
grounded and have the action be a little
more masculine and muscular and yeah as
opposed to just playing the jokes and
some fans of the original series said
hey it's the originals goofier you guys
are you know you got comedy but you got
real action in there it's it's not the
same tone and I remember Chris Rock
ironically wanted to play Maxwell Smart
this is before I knew Chris or knew that
he was interested in that but after the
movie came out we had already done
Longest Yard at that point and he called
me and said you stuck to that tone I
love it and that's brave and I didn't
understand what he meant and said what
do you mean you know but then I you know
heard the fans talking and it's like
yeah when you
mess with a tone of something you know
sometimes you can you can get some
friction ironically then look at 21 Jump
Street as a straight up comedy that's
not what the original TV series was
people loved it
so it's interesting you know when you
can rub people the wrong way by just
changing you know some aspect of the
original just you know just a hair to
the left of the hair to the right I
would never have seen heba's whatever
his name is I think the more losing I
like that accent that he has so it would
still keep yep patois first time I saw a
live longer sure we went to the Super
Bowl do you remember that which long has
he had hours to remake yeah okay and I
didn't get flown in by Sony Telemundo
flew me in oh because Adam kept pushing
me to Latino market so tell him you know
put me in there and they put me in a
condo and between Emily and Michael
Irvin and I remember that we I think
Burt was there you were there with the
duo super-mo I did not it was a couple
guys there if I was like the odd man out
because I wasn't there with the crew I
was there with Telemundo and they did
like uh a screening of the [ __ ]
trailer and I gotta be honest she I went
back to the room and I cried when I saw
Adam pull his finger in his mouth and
put his thing and the guys here I nearly
cried like I was like I was never so
embarrassed in my life
I go you just ruined this tough-guy
movie with this [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
finger in the ear I was pissed for about
three days then I went to the second
screening at Panama and then I started
falling in love with it
I saw what had been done and then I
remembered that were artists we I don't
want to see the same movie mm-hmm if you
do a remake I don't want to see the same
movie but I do want you to keep it in
the same vein mm-hmm that's all I ask
keep it in the same vein the Deathwish
they did with Bruce Willis you
disrespect the Charles bro
you disrespected me when you did that
when you did the mechanic with that guy
I love that guy
we ain't no mechanic you [ __ ] it up
the mechanic was the guy that killed a
position he didn't kill you with a
bullet he killed you by faking stuff he
did different things to you to kill you
so on the around them that's certificate
it didn't come up like you died from
that and everybody got healthy
this guy's blowing up [ __ ] buildings
that's not the [ __ ] mechanic mm-hmm
that's not an illustration of me with
the mechanic I want to see the 2018
mechanic
this guy's got electronics child Bronson
you know the mechanic opens up no not
his it's not it's it's a [ __ ]
30-minute no line mr. ass not one
[ __ ] money and it's Charles Bronson
downtown LA walks into a hotel checks
and Mosel he goes into his room sets up
a telescope watches this guy this guy
gets up leaves for the day and Charles
Bronson goes back in and you see Charles
Bronson his stuff and his tea bags
getting one of his favorite books
sticking glue balls and books and the
guy comes back and sure enough he puts
the [ __ ] tea on and it was sleeping
pills in the tea and the guy lays down
and Charles Bronson takes the rifle this
is after 20 minutes there's not one
[ __ ] line the direct is sucking you
the [ __ ] in and all sudden they show
Charles Bronson points at the book in
the thing and he shoots a bullet at the
book and the building blows up and the
next day there was a fire and the guy
dies nobody knows that's how articulate
he was he found out another guy had a
heart condition so he took them golfing
and he had somebody shoot at him so when
the guy ran inside of our attack when
they did the remake they didn't use that
they just showed me a guy that what
would do in 2008 paint blow people up
that's not the mechanic so I appreciate
a lot of things from remakes and there's
a lot of things from remakes that go a
little bit too old
I like that smart I loved I grew up on
the age of 99 I wanted a [ __ ] cut too
when I came from Cuba I wanted a [ __ ]
car Diana
Mary Tyler Moore they were all gonna get
a dick when I got on say that's a nice
sandwich that's how I learned how to
speak English by watching Dick Van Dyke
yeah by watching although show so I felt
diana rigg was on a show when I was a
kid that was a brilliant English show
and even though I didn't like English
accents then it was tougher for me to
understand an English accent diana rigg
was on a show that was on channel 9 in
New York City channel 9 is also known
for having the Mets and the Avengers The
Avengers Cece came they've got a remake
of that yeah The Avengers was her and a
little English dude right and she would
do a bunch of crazy [ __ ] not Captain
America unless it went yeah it's not
America right it's [ __ ] your bank but
that's weird how you said that they're
not well I did spider-man to like listen
let's be honest long as you're in Santa
Fe was as good as it gets in my world
the smoothie girls the umbrella oh my
god the people [ __ ] with table a bull
lady who came up to you with a tray of
coke cuts goodness family by the way do
you know why why we were so we get there
for training camp and that's like the
closest I got to playing Tom Landry
right I'm walking around with my
playbook and all you guys are on the
field training right in full pads and
I'm you know I didn't have to play
director that day you know cuz Mark
Ellis is running the football
you know we designed the plays together
but now he's getting everyone in shape
you got you know a bill Romanowski who's
acting like he's still playing and he's
like to the some accurate jogs by him
goes hey whose jersey was untucked tuck
that [ __ ] in and he was taking it
seriously and you know I it was it was
unbelievable but one day it was actually
that same afternoon clouds in the sky
look like a storm was rolling in and
Sandler was pissed
he said his Berardi our producer come
over Michael no uh no berry berry and he
says
what do you not see out on that field
because I don't know what do you see a
bunch of guys in football uniforms right
no girls
I want water girls I want water girls I
want around cold cuts I I want these
guys to be happy and Barry looked at me
like what that [ __ ] I'm like it's not a
bad idea you know because he said we're
gonna be however many guys we were you
know you know large cast in a desert in
a prison let's not have it feel like a
desert prison let's have a little bit of
you know femininity and so that's that's
why we were served you know water and
smoothie smoothie shake yeah little cups
dixie cups protein shakes and you would
just sit there and drink like ten of
them like you ant virus but the girl
that came around with the coke cuts it
was something from another world like
you know those cigarette girl yeah so
yeah with a little tray I get it and you
just have ham and cheese and some
[ __ ] cheddar cheese no no no no no
they had everything
prosciutto [ __ ] the ham gabagool
rolls to me no they were rolls yeah and
it was it was like they kept coming at
you it was like being that Fogo de Chao
putting the green light like within
between takes but the weirdest thing
though is so there's that you're you're
eating luxurious
right in a prison that had the worst
riot in US history
so I'm scouting this place and I go into
one of the cells and I got two guys from
the Film Commission with me
one was a Native American long ponytail
and then his sidekick and I'm in a
prison cell and I'm looking out the
window at beautiful Santa Fe New Mexico
desert and I said you know this is not a
bad prison I mean if I was gonna commit
a crime not a bad cell and they look at
each other like they just seen a ghost
uh-huh
what was that I come back to LA and I'm
interviewing people to be on the crew
the one guy comes in and he's kind of
bashing white because you know where
you're shooting don't you and I said no
and he hands me a book and it's called
the devil's butcher-block the story of
the riot at that prison and ice and I
started to read it and it was 38 people
were killed and they were somebody got
into the key room and from the key room
they went into the tool shed and got the
tools and then went into cellblock C
which was where the snitches were they
pull them all out and they chopped them
up bold down the hallways with their
heads stack the body parts in the gym
set it on fire so when I go there
Ichabod Crane as I used to call him he
was this caretaker of that wing of the
prison like to give tours did you get a
tour no he loved giving loving tours I
walk away with him they told me that the
floor wouldn't stay the comment correct
he said the bloodstains kept coming back
they died about leeched them away and
the blood would come back yes I have to
read he can't be so he started she shows
the chop marks in the floor where they
chopped heads off with shovels that the
chips from the shovels are still there
and after a while the players started
getting so [ __ ] freaked out I got
pissed I said you got a board up
cellblock C and no more Ichabod Crane
Ghost Tours
this has got to stop because it's we're
doing a comedy you know it's getting
[ __ ] freaked out and so we're eating
prosciutto I remember my kids you know
playing catch you know on the field and
it's sort of like you're going around
Gettysburg you feel it it's like
palpable you felt like people died here
and I literally hyperventilated the next
time I went back to the prison as I was
going through the gate because like it's
next to an hour's walk through that
Supermax yeah and so this was abandoned
what now Homeland Security would use it
to like train so you go down in to the
lower level where the chop marks are
you're walking through and the lights
are out and you go to the gas chamber
or the electric chair right and in and
out certain hallways because of Homeland
Security they have dummies for like
targets to shoot and so you're walking
along and suddenly a dummy and you
[ __ ] freak out like Jesus and it's a
dummy and I remembered I don't remember
this Jack G Adams producing partner
dared his assistant for a thousand
thousand bucks spend the night in the
electric chair room
with the lights out with all that [ __ ]
that I just said dummies chop marks
blood that won't erase I'll give you a
thousand bucks I got so pissed I said do
not take that bet I'm gonna freak out
just thinking about you down there don't
do it he did it he spent that I spent
the night I don't think it was haunted I
remember like about Oh
somebody was another bad juju it didn't
need to be haunted when we did that the
prison shots I had to go into the
building they told me come over here go
into the building and take prisoner
shots and the day I was taking the
prisoner shots
that's when a guy went off on me I don't
know if it was Ichabod Crane whoever was
standing in there we gave you the tour
why'd he give it even he started telling
me that they had taken the heads yeah
they're putting them on sticks yeah like
after a big bowling with the heads and
[ __ ] like that and when the cops came in
when the cop seized the prison
the lights were shut off and they
noticed that there was a lot of water it
was like those 12 kids in Thailand they
were walking in the water and when they
turn the lights on it wasn't water it
was blood oh Sh it was rivers and piles
of blood that were running like that
time with blood to read this book oh my
god you don't want to read no no it's
gonna freak out so it read yeah but
that's where we people don't realize
that that's what we did the soldier
Hamid II so the first day when we shot
Adam run Indian in oh my god I
remembered I brought a rabbi in I think
it's what
yeah rabbi came in with a small 50 if
you remember what he did
he pissed him off too because the guy
had he burned some incense a some herb
right he was blessing and then Sandler
said right afterwards hey can i smoke
some of that now and the guy looked at
him like if there could have been a clap
of thunder I went holy [ __ ] I hope you
just didn't jinx us but he had to crack
a joke you know it's it's it's I thought
that I was very lucky in the beginning
of you know there wasn't no hundred
holiday movies you know when I moved
here there was enough for 35 it was all
scale +10 and you went from there you
know and I still remember going to a
commercial shoot in 1990 from 97 to 2000
if he went to a commercial shoot when
you sign then it would say the product
Breyers ice cream and it would say you
know one salesman whatever the roles and
then they would go and shoots September
15th through the 18th when you got the
call guess what you worked all three
days for two days you sat there and
watched other people shoot their
commercials
Briar's wasn't really shooting one
commercials were shooting three what a
day they would hire you when you sat
there for two days they paid you scale
plus ten and they knew it
just in case something happened and they
wanted to shoot that commercial again
and they wanted to catch something if
you got a movie in those days I always
got over the time I still got the ticket
stubs like my first couple TV shows you
would sit there and then over time
that'll dissipate like in spider-man 2
you know that we lobster tails on the
Sony on Fridays you don't know that so
when you see a movie this is 160 million
you have to consider that how much of
that is waste like mm-hmm they had this
was 2003 when I shot spider-man to
pomegranate juice number was at $5 a
bottle they would have half gallons out
and I would just take a gallon bring it
to my room I didn't [ __ ] know
you know what those half gallons are
hey you should have 100 hours a day
movie and there's no wardrobe check that
fixed link off your shirt there's nobody
that fixes your hat what you look like
there's what you get like [ __ ] yeah
what you look like is what you look like
then you can do The Longest Yard where
they actually had a tattoo you in the
morning when all time was 4:45 yeah and
4:45 and those animals who I just did
his podcast Steve Austin oh yeah those
animals were out till 1 or 2 four nights
a week yeah I don't know how they would
they would they would close that hotel
bar down that boom then gee had three
seats yeah no one tells the director
these things didn't want to freak me out
so I never heard any of this come on you
guys were like all tucked in bed by 9:00
no those guys would go to Alburquerque
there was really no action in Santa Fe
no a lot of art galleries by the heart
galleries there was one strip club
it wasn't I went and then tried to do
comedy one night and they threw me out I
was going to comment
nobody disken done there's not one open
[ __ ] Mike in Santa Fe New Mexico
yeah but they had a Dunkin Donuts we had
cars and we could drive up that little
strip of land like there was less
cruises I went to Albuquerque one time I
realized they shot cops damn I never
went back again all those guys are good
Albuquerque for the weekends I was like
[ __ ] to you I would stay up there with
the Seattle Seahawk would always stay
well II never went back
Brian Bosworth oh yeah yeah and a couple
guys would stay the weekend I remember
one time I was a camera in the name of
the hotel in Santa Fe Oh staying as the
middle of the shoot and they told me
they said um this Saturday you need to
move out of your cousin Arnold then you
can move back in son I'm like you're
really gonna kick me out of my well we
have a VIP who's coming in this is his
favorite room so I said really
okay and I moved out for one night and
then on the set one day someone says a
Pete the governor wants to talk to you
I'm like what and so they hand me a
phone
buta I just wanna tell you thank you
very much
letting me stay in the room it's this
personal convenience for me and he just
was thanking me I was like this is so
cool
and you don't want they has to leave Oh
Nellie really cuz he was smoking pot in
the hotel I didn't want Arnold to smoke
it so they asked Nellie to leave for two
or three days oh really
yes Oh for sportspeople he was probably
close to you you know I didn't know
Nellie was in your way there was a
certain wing that they closed off around
that week cellblock C way yes I'm glad
she went and stuff like that Wow
interesting
you know I always want to ask you when
you I mean I love Tommy Boy you know I
miss Chris Farley it's so weird that I
think about the last time I saw Chris
Farley and there was one of the saddest
things I ever saw in Hollywood but I had
gone through what he was going through
my girlfriend was a stripper I'm letting
it I had just left the comedy store this
is two weeks before he died
this is 98 right what did he die huh I
think the alien December 18th of 98 this
had to be two weeks three weeks before
he died at that strip club there's no
contact allowed they danced naked you
can't touch him there's no lap dances
what you could do is hire them to dance
nude but they have to stand 5 feet from
you and there's a rope I don't want to
do that that seems just stupid I can't
grab you like they're [ __ ] the Harvey
am saying for the small file hours but
it was so funny how my girlfriend at the
time I said park the car you gotta see
this
okay okay and I said I didn't know what
she was gonna show me it was his Farley
sweating profusely yeah he was sweating
so much that his hair was back yeah like
a shirt alone and he was just rolling up
50s and 20s and gone a lap dance and
just throwing about I've been looking at
him come on
everything in my heart want to go up and
give that guy a hug I'm a comic you like
everything and you overhear that
expression don't talk to the celebrities
you look up to because you might be
disappointed
like I remember going in that car being
[ __ ] really sad hmm but I saw one
that was a little chubby at the time so
I looked up to him Belushi you know and
that was the last time I saw Julie after
that he was probably got a tooth three
weeks and I was like that's [ __ ] up
that I saw him that night acting that
way at a strip club giggling by himself
he was totally bummed so yeah so with
him well I sort of straddled two sides
of his personality because I started
working with him in television he was in
an HBO special I did with Tom Arnold and
Ben Stiller and Jim Carrey were in it
and I remember him showing me and I was
shooting with Chris Farley we went to
the Glendale Galleria and we're just
falling around with a camera as he was
picking up on girls it was pee in your
pants hilarious he would like walk up to
a girl and say can't kidding with
holding an orange and say hi Kent King
Jeff fingernails can you start my orange
for me I can't peel it and then he'd
just start flirting with hilarious stuff
right after that he'd so that was for
HBO then we did the Jackie Thomas show
and he played Tom's brother and right
after that episode I radically knew that
what year was in Jackie Thomas 97 no 91
no I was different damn it for a
different Thomas show well they put him
straight in a limo and took him to rehab
so when I was working with him he was
still you know hi and abusing stuff um
Tommy Boy he was clean and ironically
I'm shooting this prepping his movie in
Toronto
I haven't been to Toronto since I shot
Tommy Boy 24 years ago he was clean
there and he always went to his priest
at night and that was his AAA and you
know right after Tommy Boy he there were
a lot of things offered to Chris because
he kind of blew up and the things that
were offered to him I thought were
terrible and he kept saying well do this
with me Pete do this it's terrible it's
terrible and I said no no and he got
really upset with me you thought I
didn't like him anymore and he was mad
at me and I had to write him like a
seven-page letter tell him how much i is
absolutely wrong
I adored him I just wanted the best for
him I thought he could get nominated for
an Oscar one day if he chose properly
but don't cash in on this crap you're
being offered right now wait you know
choose and he forgave me
it was soon thereafter that he passed
and we never got to work together again
and I always felt sad about that you
know but going back to Toronto lately
it's like all these memories are
flooding back I'd literally stood at the
good omen warts distillery last week
which was Callahan Auto and they built
an apartment building where the front
gate was I was a little disoriented
remember we entered somewhere and it's
not here anymore and then finally I
stood in the middle of the courtyard
where he sat thinking about you know his
father who passed away and I went holy
[ __ ] I know exactly where I am
oh my god and almost got emotional
because I was like I'm standing where
Chris sat and I could barely recognize
it but the buildings are historical
landmarks so they didn't touch the
actual buildings but they just put so
many condos around it it was hard to
recognize but know he you know I talked
to Spade every now and then and Fred
wolf and I are you know who wrote the
movie are still good friends still
around press still around yeah I see the
one brother around
don't yell Farley bridge on CEO Kevin I
know both of them yeah one lived down
the corner from the young gardener
mm-hmm and the other one I knew from
auditions and whatnot damn stand up with
David he's always around with spades
they're great guys yeah I think he hangs
out with so he opens for Spade when I
moments for Spade that's the one I see
they great guy yep I mean when I was a
kid I loved [ __ ] blue bar blues
brothers a song last night one night and
I sat there and laughed my ass yeah and
I was thinking about how I used to weigh
Lutz in like 1980 and there was a pizza
parlor my neighborhood and the guy was
his racist as [ __ ]
he was great his name was Nick Nick's
pizza and he would just tell you what
was on his mind he was and he had the
accident like [ __ ] you know everyone go
on in there one night go Nick when we
got a [ __ ] Sicilian he's like [ __ ]
you you [ __ ] speak
and I took the red crushed pepper and I
do have a missile - a he's a good at
look at the shape oh I know what
happened I puked you got my shirt that
was in there or quaalude it out he's
like look at you you look like Belushi
so ever since that he would always call
me [ __ ] by Lucien get the [ __ ]
[ __ ] Belushi he was he would today
got arrested that first simple Italy
correctly miss there's a kid in my
neighborhood that now is an assembly but
he's a big deal but his family always on
the funeral they've always very
successful well he was a kid he would
get a slice of mix but he would cross
the street to hash ways because the ice
tea was a nickel cheaper and Nick would
be talking to me going where's [ __ ]
bunny and we go he what the hatchways
cuz the iced tea is cheaper across the
road now this is the torah' Boulevard
cars everywhere Nick would walk out to
the ministry nobody you [ __ ] Jew you
suck like I always loved candy oh yeah I
always loved all those big guys yeah so
this dad or Jim candy yeah when Tommy
boys on I watch all that [ __ ] all those
late might say that lives with Chris
Farley the Chicago [ __ ] makes me [ __ ]
high my ass yeah so weird that like I
have the opportunity now like I'm still
[ __ ] kicked heaven 55 and those guys
are gone and there was one time when I
was just as crazy as those guys it's so
[ __ ] sad to me like I huh there's
every three days I sit there and go what
made me quit that [ __ ] huh and quit it
for good like it never came into a
thought there was never a real app like
once I said enough that was it you know
you're lucky I'm very [ __ ] right and
you look gorgeous you dropped a lot of
weights and so yeah 55 with a five year
old nice you know you gotta uh you
really you hear the expression for years
and you nod your head at your friends
and you say yeah and you give
some [ __ ] story but they come today
you really really have to look after
yourself it's like being a good friend
to yourself you know you go home at 9:00
you really want to eat that haagen-dazs
but you eat two apples instead you get a
jell-o pudding that's got three points
you know you really want the [ __ ]
haagen-dazs then the more you yell your
wife forget the [ __ ] come on yeah that's
why I do the shopping yeah because I
don't buy the [ __ ] that I know after a
glass of wine and I'm gonna eat you look
great well thank you no no for a guy
that works on films because people have
no idea what a directors day is like and
what's in front of them yeah what's in
funny you have no idea like you don't
know the call for the day yeah and
everyone saw why you could come up to
the first ad and say bring me a salad
from Chipotle oh yeah but besides that
you're so consumed with the film if you
really consumed with the film you're not
even thinking you just I want to hit the
lunch break and then see I lose great I
lose weight making movies because
there's so much stress right so I had an
assistant once when at when lunch would
come up you know and they hand around
you know the menu here's what's Tess and
dude I make ten thousand decisions a day
have this decision be yours you know the
three things I eat chicken whatever and
chicken so just get me whatever you know
I don't want to look at a menu so we we
go and when they they turn the lights
out in the dailies trailer you know we
there's an 18-wheeler it's got pop outs
and that's where we look at the footage
from the day before the food gets
delivered and as soon as it gets
delivered
you know they turn out the lights and
then your plate is lit by the screen you
know that you're watching every time I'd
look down
I'd hear a laugh and I missed it so I
said [ __ ] I can't cut with a knife and
fork so whatever you get me his name was
Skippy whatever you get me Skippy I got
to pick it up with my hands like an
animal I was gonna like a caveman in my
K and I just pick it up whatever was
chicken breast great cuz I can hold it
after a while I guess I got picky about
what I was eating and the lights would
turn on and
Dean Semler look at me and it goes night
what was wrong with your face I said
what do you mean is that you got rattled
around your mouth and I got a terrible
Australian accent by the way but I
looked down at my plate and I'm eating
coleslaw and strawberries with my hand I
go how whenever I'm eating this [ __ ] he
was well I didn't want to bug you
anymore because you got picky about your
food so you hadn't said anything in a
couple of weeks so I've been eating
coleslaw and strawberries with my hands
you know so that you know I [ __ ]
myself on that one
how is the stress on those films it's uh
I remember my first movie you know back
in were shooting in 93 Naked Gun I've
gone from making you know television to
a thirty five million dollar budget I
remember my mother telling me man your
balls are really on the line I went
thanks mom that's so comforting thank
you and then you know when the numbers
you first salmon movie I did you know
anger management with Jack Nicholson was
like 75 million they don't make those
like I was saying before they don't make
those anymore but so it's not just then
I worked with Adam Sandler for the first
time although I'd known Adam through
Farley and spade and you know guys who'd
bump into each other so I'm working with
him he was at the height of his career
very powerful Jack Nicholson doesn't get
any bigger and then everybody wanted to
be in that movie Woody Harrelson John
Turturro etc and you can't my brother
asked me my brother was left he was a
editor-in-chief of Los Angeles Magazine
just left and now he's heading the news
for NASA JPL
god bless him and he said to me um don't
you ever get nervous I said I literally
don't have time to get nervous when I'm
on the set it's like business and so
that's how it was wait it just be so
focused on what you have to do and I'm
you know very responsible you know so I
don't want to go over I'm a good Jew
that way bad Jew religiously
recreational Jew so um but III don't
want to go over ever so I don't but
that's another pressure you know to keep
that Hey
you remembered Santa Fe keep that
juggernaut going when not only to deal
with football and and prison and ghosts
and all this but every day at 3:00 in
the afternoon we'd have a [ __ ]
tornado you know we were shooting during
a monsoon season and Nelly had to go on
tour on Fridays he had to shoot
everything until Wednesday morning yeah
st. oh I mean it was there were days
that I don't know I when I looked at you
you didn't look stressed during the
longest shot but I knew it was hard on
everybody it's a good genius to figure
out that there was too many people know
there's it was crazy I was it was crazy
look if I have a superpower at all it's
I look calmer on the outside than I am
on the inside was you I knew was a lot
of stress on you I knew there was days
that he was directing a movie that would
even look at you like that it was just
there was no time yeah
there was no crazy go Pete what do you
want from me on this you gotta give me a
thing
yeah just do what you did yeah you know
I still remember going up to Adam
Redondo Beach it was the day that Nelly
released his two albums that we need
took us to the party do you remember
that huh it was like September because
we went to Santa feeling July and August
then we came back and had a week off and
then we went down to work and I'll never
forget the day like once we got up here
the game changed a little but there was
no more umbrella girls right you mean
back to California back to California
and I've started lingering a little bit
yep that was really funny that one day
we're doing the lock the sand and I'm
sitting them 395 pounds I'm like damn
one of my favorite sports movies again
we all all maje is one of my favorite
sports movies in Major League I think
they did a great job with major league
and a Cuban the major league is now a
[ __ ] huge story there's Allstate
commercials right but there was one
scene when the owner comes up to him and
he's got a jock on and she smacks him in
the ass and he's Cuban I go you know
what what if I [ __ ] him more jock I'll
never forget that Adam was talking the
two
guys from Parramatta and you guys would
make a wardrobe decisions and I go out
put this [ __ ] joke on that was your
idea
oh yeah so you're the guy that says I
was sickened by him doing a wet willy to
him and then you come out in the jogs
around and that's okay because this is a
real football scene with real prisoners
let me explain something
I saw along this yard that's all the
longest you are at the Union City cinema
the weekend they came out and there was
two movies I had got like we went to
everything in those days that was that
came out in 73 right original Longest
Yard yeah 73 look at what came out with
73 I mean you were up against that was
76-73 was deliverance I think
deliverance yeah I had a book cuz I mean
there was only two movies and I went to
see everything at the cinema from
Charles Bronx 74 Canal
yeah 74 so I was 11 and they will let
you in the cinema didn't give a [ __ ] if
you were 10 for whatever when they gave
they had that movie about the devil the
axis is Kansas ya know the Exodus came
out and then sometime somebody tried to
be even more gross and they came out
with this other horror movie towards 74
where they gave you puke bags on the way
and you had to be a time the 18 you
gotta come with your mother they didn't
give a [ __ ] they just gave you a puke
bag the devil's lair or whatever but one
thing I'm I'm up along a shot first of
all my mother had the ball so there's a
lot of shady characters that hung man
and I went to this Union City sent him I
like a look in the eye Pete when I so
long as yard when it ended the movie
theater was on their feet
yelling mean machine like this is 1974
the other movie that we were on our feet
for was rocky that movie theater 300
people said you're standing on your
seats just people that don't really call
those theater attendants they would kept
telling us to sit on father's yeah the
ushers were like [ __ ] you mean machine
mean machine so well I thought a mean
machine I thought we were gonna be a
bunch of [ __ ] bad asses you know I'm
saying like I just didn't know he's
gonna be more of a comedic that's what
is it yeah so no that was my idea I went
up to
we said dog we pull each I think one of
the guys said no and the other guy
didn't like me not bury Bernardi but the
other guy and me had gone to war over a
bet because he couldn't pick a [ __ ]
winner what was his original part his
name the attorney uh Jack T Jack G
couldn't pick a [ __ ] winner if isn't
they depend on he couldn't the prob'ly
luckiest day he ever had was the best
dog I hit by a car it was his younger
brother with membership you know
whenever I play Long Island his brother
shows up oh yeah he still shows up the
younger brother so Jack Jim me
Jack G was like down he came through me
because what do you think about this
game so I told him but he lost he
started getting pissed off at me so Jack
G was there when I went up to him he's
like absolutely no I wasn't talking to
you bro
hahaha I was not [ __ ] talking yeah
you know we're at that point the woman
tempers were flaring a little yeah
getting towards man that was that was
also the day that somebody threw this
shirt and Michael Irvin who Michael
Irvin didn't catch it and it landed on
the floor this is a very interesting
story in romanovski stepped on it and
then [ __ ] off from the Seattle
Seahawks stepped on it and Michael Oher
everything what looked at ball told me
knows that's great
real [ __ ] mature because it doesn't
matter because when I play both he is in
college all you [ __ ] seen was
and he tied the shirt around like it was
a cape and he ran past him he goes this
is all you guys ever saw me anyway it
was me doing this like running every
[ __ ] like romanovski and the other
guy had nowhere to go
let's have his were already start
somewhere and Rob was asking and called
out the fighter not the big guy yep that
Bob Sapp Maurice MIT that was almost a
fight in the [ __ ] poor section one
day that the staff didn't find out about
no bill we were on our side we were had
the wrestlers across from it was me Nick
Bill Goldberg yeah and Romanowski was
somewhere with his Hawaiian wife and one
day [ __ ]
he just went up to Marvin whatever it
said some weird stuff there and I've
been salivary had to come out Bob Sapp
had to come out and one of the wrestlers
stood in the middle that was the end of
that a lot of testosterone that [ __ ]
said but you know what is interesting I
just remembered you know especially
since Burt Reynolds just passed you
remember the day Burt had an idea he
said I just want to do some stuff it was
like we had finished the day he says can
I can I have some of the players over
here I just have some ideas and that
scene where he pulls you by your helmet
down to the ground remember there was no
script for that he just he and I thought
I have no idea what he's doing he just
wants to he said I got some ideas I just
want to do some coaching stuff so he
brought you and a few other players and
dilip so Leipsic I remember and and I
just thought to myself what is going on
here but let's try it you know I have
you know at that scene it's about the
rain yeah of course rain you couldn't
know ever was like that scene didn't
know Brando that day because it was just
by the time he lit it it got darker yeah
but if you watch those things also
getting to be neighbors get to be
nighttime yeah so you could see the
contrast but I'll never forget that I
didn't know what he wanted neither me
neither and then he just said you line
up in position or horn stance and then
he just Yanks you by your house almost
took your head off I couldn't believe
how strong yeah I got that mobile I hit
the floor I don't let him put me up come
on big guy get up let's do this scene
again and now I was prepared for the Yak
I wasn't prepared for the Yak when he
first now me that's in the movie that's
in the movie oh yeah yeah I was hoping
that state keeps that that's Burt
Reynolds touching me that's all that
matters I can function now the Doomsday
outfit
well I remember also Burt was not
supposed to do when he comes into the
game he was not supposed to actually run
that play and it was against Bosworth
and he said Pete let me do it I got it
don't put my stunt man and I got it to
it and I thought we could actually kill
burr
channels on this play as at Bert really
the nobody none of the producers want
you to do this we got to put your stuff
let me do it kid
let me do it so we let him do it
Bosworth tackled him god I went a little
easier on him then he would have and I
remember picking bird up and said kid he
just added ten years to my life never
forget that he would have tears in his
eyes he uh it was really weird last week
because I don't get emotional you know
I'm I can't tweet thumb [ __ ] but it was
so weird how he died and I did some
stuff and I was like wow that's a shame
that he died he was a good guy and then
I went to the room of the computer and
my daughter came in and there's
everything she gives me a hang-up you
know she gave me a picture and a patch
was on the picture and she wanted to
take the patch off the picture so when I
took the picture off the wall there was
there's a picture of me Bert Goldberg
dictatorial and Adam and he wrote you
know good always love your brother
Bert and I took the picture down i sat
there for five minutes I was like
talking about the prison I got stuck
back in the seventh grade I got a GED
but in all this I got to spend six weeks
with Burt Reynolds two trailers down for
me and I would be smoking at the moment
his potty go don't you as a federal
prisoner and they stopped he always so
right then and there like I got
emotional I go I'm [ __ ] lucky am I
I want to see how long is your and all
the smoking ban that movies I went to
see all that little whorehouse in Texas
I was I was a fan you know when I met
him there was two people blow me away at
the lunch it was him and Luther the guy
that was 48 hours and oh yeah yeah Steve
you never have you ever work with them
again have you ever not since No
I've been touch for a long time and I
would do shows in the city that he would
show up peter segal he would show up and
people go [ __ ] Luther's here for 48
hours people would freak the [ __ ] out
when they saw ya
you know the guys from the Warriors he
told us yeah he told us how he got that
that when he moved he was a musician
from Detroit they moved to New York and
he lived in the Bronx he was had long
hair and that every night the Italians
would play bottles and go dirty air come
out and play-ay
so when he got worried that's where he
got that thing with the bottles I don't
know it's [ __ ] crazy this shot you
learned all this time what did you learn
from Jennifer Lopez she's a great
actress she really is blew me away she
is you know she kind of went through a
little bit what I did in her experience
with doing television you know will you
crank out 10 pages a day she had to
learn you know cuz the old movie
business when you're doing two pages a
day two and a half pages a day it's
luxurious and super slow you're doing
ten pages a day you better know your
[ __ ] so she was prepared and when a when
an actor is prepared you get to play
more you get to try things and it's a
very sweet story you know it's it's very
funny but it's emotional and it's
inspirational it's about you know second
acts in life you know when you think
that you're you're done and you you know
you talk about it with your podcast you
who said you know a little less acting
and now you've got new lease on what
you're doing you know and that's what
her character goes through in that movie
and in a way you know I had done all
these male driven movies this was my
second act you know I did something very
different you know it's a sort of a
chick flick you know the guys liked it
too but I know who my audience is in
this one you know but she's great and
charming and I got to tell you you know
we've almost worked together a few times
over the years but she's never been
bigger
she's a frickin brand now she's on TV -
right she's television she
Vegas she's movies she's you know just
was the VMA you know video Vanguard
Michael Jackson between those seas um I
don't know anyone who works harder I
don't know I don't get it how hard she
was she started to show Ray Liotta
yeah that's finishing that's wrapping up
and so I think it might have finished
its but she's got world of dance which
is huge and like I said she's still
doing Vegas I just heard a commercial
you know for her Vegas thing from the
Tourism Board in Nevada and she's got
now the movie thing is kicking back in
she's sort of not done that nobody's got
comedy chops though she does she's got
comedy chops she does you know what she
was good at you know it was a bad movie
but she was really good at the Hector
Lavoe story the ACMA Laveau story was
because if you don't remember right one
of the costume designers on The Longest
Yard was her costumer for years I don't
know the blonde
there was the blonde so the blonde
brought in the script actor Laveau and
gave it to me hmm
she goes I don't love you know
Jennifer's doing this if you see
something you want to audition for it
there was really nothing for me to
audition for in that movie but she plays
a crazy wife a Puerto Rican wife and
she's [ __ ] funny yeah look like I
said the movie when she was married to
Marc Anthony at the time so she shot it
with Marc Anthony uh-huh the movies not
Academy Award winner but she did pretty
[ __ ] yeah yeah she did she's got really
good so did you see yourself at USC
College doing all this [ __ ] you doing
now 20 years later 30 years later did
you graduate from the US I graduated 84
and I wanted to be a pro football player
so I walked on football team at SC as a
punter let's quarterback in high school
but I said I'm not gonna make it as a
quarterback but I could kick and made
the first two cuts and then got cut but
the coolest thing
ironically again relates back to Longest
Yard the guy who beat me out with Sean
Salsbury who became our quarterback
the longest yard so I got to tell him
you ended my football career but thank
you because without you I may not have
gone into what I'm doing now
because I got an internship at local CBS
and that began my segue into a world I
never thought I'd get into I can never
forget this either we're standing there
in a circle Sean Sean Asbury comes in
saying hellos to everybody how you doing
what's going on
I picked Romanowski goes what's that
[ __ ] mutt doing here
[Laughter]
like you know and you know Romo said it
so he could hear it yeah he goes what's
that [ __ ] mutt doing here and when
Sean Salsbury was for free from II
looked at Roman Roman good he goes what
are you gonna do teach these
quarterbacks how they get psyched
[Laughter]
Salzburg is like you've never changed
that never what the [ __ ] do not the call
by teacher mother get sacked
did you ever do karate oh my god I never
heard that story no there was a couple
good [ __ ] on there hello you know like I
said I was a virgin I had done like ten
movies where I was three days or less I
think the longest dad had the longest
stint I had was a movie with Rodney
Dangerfield that there wasn't no
character he liked me so much he just
told me what to comment yeah yeah we'll
find some freedom oh no kid just coming
I'd have to knock on his door and he'd
have a robot his dick was eyeballs
around I got [ __ ] she's wrong the joint
it's blowing up everywhere should I come
in the wrong Jojo come in what he so I
had never been in this [ __ ] 17-week
yeah we shot so much garbage at the end
I am thought I was sitting on why are we
still here do you have a night like
everybody was wrapped it was me and Lobo
we shot a scene and me tattooing Lobos
back oh yeah I do
she won a joy behar but I put like
Roseanne Barr on his back yeah oh my god
we can't even remember that
we've ever kept that was the night I
mean there had to be eight of us we were
shooting like four six scenes and
[ __ ] Adam got a chocolate fountain
what dog you think I'm kidding yet
suddenly he got a fountain that was made
out of chocolate with chocolate fudge
with fondue all you did was nice to
different just [ __ ] fun though
are you kidding me we that we did that
scene never made one scene that was just
horrible we could not get to work that
is the one of the best scenes in the
movie is when they're in the infirmary
in the original it's one of the best
scenes of movie they throwing toilet
paper at each other and then cheering
they just won the guys all hurt in the
infirmary we shot that that never made
it was god-awful I don't even remember
that me it was like me and two other
guys but I didn't have nobody to work
offer you didn't give me somebody
comedic ly so you gave me two wrestlers
and the guy from the Giants I couldn't
get up with him I'm gonna guy that won
the championship with the Giants he was
number 55 for the Giants he was a white
dude yeah he was in that movie he's like
a friend of Adams and [ __ ] oh yeah yeah
yeah you had him in the infirmary all
the guards that Steve Austin who got his
dick knocked out and somebody else got
knocked out I was the only guy I'd
knocked out by Romo yeah so I was in the
infirmary we shut the infirmary scene
which I was excited for yeah I'm like
this is a great scene I'm throwing
toilet paper at them I'm telling them to
go [ __ ] themselves we just yeah
well it was horrific we'll see you're a
comic at least you know when it's bad
you know and you're not comedic I do
that I'm killing what I walked out of
that ceiling well they're not gonna have
that yeah yeah that was just that bad
they have just that had it are you happy
you're doing what you don't I am I am
you know what one thing is you know
we're talking so much about The Longest
Yard but there's nothing closer that I
can imagine to actually being a
performer then when I go into a theater
and watch one of my movies that is
rockin and I remember our final test
screening in Las Vegas for Longest Yard
we got a 94 my heart was gonna
come out of my chest because like when
you know Nellie's drinking for the
touchdown and and Chris Burma's going
hey could go the whole crowd oh wait
when you're talking about the original
Longest Yard and that the crowd stood
the crowd was cheering this movie during
the game like it was an actual game and
I thought my if you took my pulse it
would be like a hundred and fifty beats
per minute it was one of the coolest
things ever walked out and Bosworth said
dude this movie's gonna blow up I
remember calling Chris Rock from my
phone saying I wish you were here
tonight in Las Vegas it was that's the
type of thing that makes me love what I
do there's a lot of crap that you got to
do it's very very hard a lot harder than
people think but when you can have a
night like that you know it's it makes
it all worth it so one couple last
questions so the when a movie goes over
budget peet they blame you I blame me
here's the thing my movies have not gone
over budget I'm pretty honest about that
pretty honest that's weird
I am honest about but you know what
James Cameron's little movie called
Titanic went way over budget
almost by double didn't matter eleven
Academy Awards one of the biggest hits
of all time I could be on budget and
have a bomb doesn't matter that I was on
budget it was a bomb so I'm not I don't
want to sound this way and make studio
execs nervous hearing this but it almost
doesn't matter I've seen people rewarded
for one and you know [ __ ] on for the
other you just gotta make it if you go
over budget and you win 11 Academy
Awards they suck your dick boy you
exactly if you go a budget you eat a bag
of dicks yeah then you're [ __ ] you
can't go you can't even get a table it's
not going directors jail it's it's so
weird how it's yeah everything is your
what off your last movie that's it yeah
and then today's economy in today's
world it's money yep which the money's
not what it used to be now don't people
aren't going to movies they got Netflix
they on this they got that you in a
tough business and when I asked you
about the stress it's just cuz
I'll tell you what man for three years I
had a hard time with Tommy the last
three years and I'd let the audience get
to me I wanted them to leave having a
good experience I know what you have to
go through to come watch me you have to
get a babysitter you have to get your
wife all dolled up she's got to shave
her monkey you got to shave your month
there's a lot to go into a comedy show
or a movie theater with your wife
especially in today's economy so if you
pay twenty seven fifty to come see you I
want to be the best I can so I play it
safe I play it safe I played on the
budget I stayed to a certain time I
finally realized I got to be myself
mm-hm so I don't give a [ __ ] no more the
audience is gonna love me whether they
know it or not well just because I
stepped out on stage and that's how I
don't want to work on a movie set like
The Longest Yard was two changes New
Mexico was relaxed is [ __ ] and then
California was now we got cameras on us
everybody's watching us I felt the
difference
I felt looser and whatever it's a
healthier environment so for you to fake
the funk and say that you wanted the
stress you had me fooled because I
laughed my ass off sugar I mean I had my
rough days because I was just that out
of shape you know when you guys were
training they were walking me around the
field with an oxygen tank I do remember
that two hoses in my nose cuz I couldn't
even breathe the Ovation so these four
that's right push-ups yeah I forgot the
elevation the elevation the elevation
was I was 400 pounds so I had an oxygen
coach that would just give me axes and
make me do like little push-ups that was
my training like just getting move your
feet up that's all I was doing Peter
sagal I'm happy you took time out of
your busy day thank you my friend love
saying come visit you come visit I did
not know that you had won eight Emmys a
local Los Angeles area they're smaller
okay whatever you still want something
it's exactly one the contest of flappers
you wanna pay that's not the best pizza
in the world but you want a pizza that's
all that has no I'm happy you took the
time I hope you come visit me again
before the movie comes out we'll get in
more detail
yeah so has she released the trailer on
her yeah it's out trailers out its
online I guess yeah wherever you find it
online but I'd go you know to her
Instagram you probably find it so
there's only 77 million other people on
there so easy to find like I said like I
said when you came in here I love you
Twitter I hope more people follow you on
twitter thank you a nice dinner where do
they go to find you on Instagram
Instagram why I got the blue check
recently oh [ __ ] yeah I got verified all
right so just I guess I just say Pete
Segal and it gets to me but if not it's
at Pete underscore Siegel you know I
like what you're doing as a director you
good people I look into your world and I
think you know now I think I just shot
something a few months ago and when I
got there and made me sign something and
they didn't want no pictures taken I
thought it was so weird I got a half a
million followers you don't want me to
take a picture of me on the TV set with
the director or one of the stars of the
show there was so social media scared we
have our own people your people suck
dick I got 11 people following me you
don't know what they're doing you just
hire the college do it I like what you
do with me that's why I kept bugging you
to come in but yeah you're onto
something when I see those pictures and
[ __ ] you're onto something
Thanks don't be a [ __ ] stranger now
when does the movie get released
Thanksgiving
so they before you after that yes so you
have to devil talk [ __ ] about the movie
and stuff like that thank you very much
for coming and taking the time and uh I
love you to death don't forget you
little dirty bastards everything sold
out this weekend
Wow where am I going Philadelphia and
[ __ ] even hey listen
hurricane huh no no hurricane could stop
me I'm getting on that plane tomorrow
tip-top Magoo headed the [ __ ] in Philly
and then Saturday night I'm at the 9:30
club but I'll see you guys
next week I want to thank peter segal
again for coming on the show you know I
love your brother anyway listen I gotta
talk to you people buy something that's
important football season is upon us
okay it's time to make some Guinness for
the holidays and you know me if it ain't
my bookie I don't [ __ ] around ever since
I started the podcast you people always
torture me who the poo do you like oh
well none I don't know dick I don't know
nothing only thing I know is my book you
gotta check it out because it's not as
important as what you're betting on and
who you're betting with cuz you want to
get paid trust me these guys are the
best bet you'll have all goddamn season
first of all if they've been in business
for years they got great reviews online
and their mobile site is easy to use I
would only recommend the service to you
guys that's been good to me that's why
I'm urging you to make your way to my
bookie you know why cuz you win and they
pay that's it they have an in-game live
betting the most rewarding player perks
in the business and see you fantasy guys
out there you can even bet the over
under and how many fantasy points a
player will score each game where do you
get that type action from my bookie
[ __ ] that's who so do me a favor go to
my bookie and join now and they'll match
your deposit you ready for this one
dollar for dollar use promo code Church
CH you are CH to activate the offer
visit my bookie online today that's my
bookie my B oh ok ie and don't forget
the for use the promo code Church CH you
are CH when creating your account to
claim up to a thousand dollars in free
play again my bookie you play you win
you get [ __ ] paid and that's the most
important thing number two you're
sitting there scratching yourself
looking at your mother and father going
I don't know I don't know what I am what
I do here's what y'all 23andme 23mm ears
of DNA testing service that could offer
insights into your ancestry health
wellness and traits 23andme health and
ancestry service includes reports on how
your DNA can influence your weight sleep
quality and caffeine intake scent to
taste and whether you're likely to be
lactose intolerant
and more and it's easy to do you just
spit into a tool provided by your
23andme kit and you mail your saliva
sample back to the lab to be analyzed
the bitter taste report versus the sweet
and salty reports yeah it the DNA play a
role in determining your food
preferences from sweet to salty too
bitter
they got sleep reports the deep sleep
report tells you if you're most likely
to be being an especially deep sleeper
the deep sleeper movement report tells
you how much you're likely to move
during your sleep based on your DNA
that's the kind of listen the
lactose-intolerant report sheds insights
are you genetics may affect your ability
to digest dairy products that's all by
just spitting into a tube and sending it
to 23andme with the kit and mail your
saliva sample back to the lab to be
analyzed it's that simple so do me a
favor
order your 23andme health and ancestry
service kit today right now today order
u.s. 23andme health and ancestry service
kit at 23andme
dot-com slash church again 23andme
dot-com slash Church that's the number
23andme calm slash Church listen you
gotta find out a lot of good stuff that
you wanted to know so go to 23andme
dot-com right now thank you thank you
for supporting the church thank you for
supporting me thank you for supporting
Lee but most importantly for listening
and being family you know I love you
[ __ ] with all my heart I'll see
you this weekend you understand me
whether it be that the [ __ ] Philly
parks casino or at the 9:30 club you bad
[ __ ] I love you
stay black Lee kick this [ __ ] meal